You know by now that
serving one single file for
every context is not a good idea.
>> Yeah, I mean, the image file
you would want to serve for
a large display size on
a big high definition TV
is totally inappropriate for
a watch, for example.
So how do you serve the right image for
every combination of device
capability and display size?
In the last lesson, you learned some
techniques that use CSS background
images in media queries to
display different images for
different viewport sizes.
That kind of works, but it was
pretty messy and difficult to debug.
To do it properly,
you potentially needed to write CSS to
handle umpteen different use cases.
And what about the future?
What if all your fancy media queries
don't support some future platform?
>> Yeah, I mean, using media
queries like this is an attempt to
guess at build time what image
file will be best at run time.
You're forcing image choice on the
browser rather than giving the browser
information to make
the best choice possible.
The other problem with media queries
is that they only refer to the viewport
dimensions, not the actual
display size of the image.
What if you give your image
a percentage width, say I don't know,
50% of the viewport width.
Media queries won't help.